Rick and Morty season 5 is coming and it's
sure to be full of all the little details
and subtle jokes that we've come to expect.
Here are a few we saw in the new trailer.
In the trailer, there's a strange-looking
character with slicked-back hair, pale blue
lips, gills on his neck, and very little clothing.
This guy is actually someone Rick detests
more than any other creature in any other
universe, and the Rick and Morty season 5
trailer isn't the first time fans have caught
a glimpse of him.
Back in July 2020, Adult Swim released a first-look
clip from the upcoming season, which features
incomplete animation of Rick and Morty escaping
monsters on a ravaged planet, Morty driving
Rick's ship and dodging flaming asteroids,
and then crashing the ship in the ocean.
Rick immediately panics, and then, the merman
emerges from a giant clamshell to taunt Rick
and Morty.
His name is Mr. Nimbus, and he's Rick's "once
and eternal foe."
"Who the [bleep] is that?"
"My nemesis."
"What?"
"My [bleep]ing nemesis, okay?"
"
Okay, but what was his name again?"
"I am Mr. Nimbus!"
Another short sequence in the season 5 trailer
depicts Morty carrying an injured Rick through
a landscape dotted with floating crystals
that look like a good place to store renegade
Kryptonian generals.
In Rick and Morty, however, these crystals
aren't gateways to the Phantom Zone; rather,
they seem to reveal alternate universe versions
of Rick and Morty.
And it wouldn't be the show we all know and
love if at least one of these alternate realities
didn't show Rick and Morty as superheroes.
As the pair trek through the field of crystals,
Rick is quick to point out the crystal that
shows the reality in which they are both versions
of the half-vampiric, vampire-killing Marvel
hero Blade, famously played on screen by Wesley
Snipes.
This seems to be a clever reference to the
bloody rave scene from Blade.
The Blade-universe crystal is only on screen
for a few seconds in the Rick and Morty season
5 trailer, but it isn't the only one that
bears weight.
Way in the back of the same shot is another
significant crystal — one that references
Rick and Morty's origins.
In the crystal, Morty's wearing a blue shirt
and a red vest, while Rick still rocks his
signature white lab coat.
If, upon closer inspection, this looks familiar
to fans, it's because they've almost definitely
seen these exact iterations of Rick and Morty
before.
This crystal's reality is a callback to "The
Real Animated Adventures of Doc and Mharti
," made by Rick and Morty co-creator Justin
Roiland in 2006.
This very-NSFW short parodies the classic
Back to the Future film series, and ultimately
formed the basis for Rick and Morty.
"Guess you guys aren't ready for that yet.
But your kids are going to love it."
Part of the fun of Rick and Morty is all the
clever satire of popular sci-fi and fantasy
properties, and season 5 looks to continue
this tradition by taking aim at two IPs in
particular.
A common sight in the trailer is the Smith-Sanchez
family geared up in a set of matching, color-coded
suits.
This feels like a clear reference to the classic
'80s cartoon Voltron.
The trailer also seems to give a hat-tip to
another popular kids TV series: Transformers.
Early on in the Rick and Morty season 5 trailer,
we see Rick's ship facing off against a humanoid
robot that bears a striking resemblance to
a Transformer, with car parts making up certain
portions of its body.
At several points in the trailer, Rick and
Beth are seen wearing some gruesome costumes
that look straight out of a horror movie.
Fittingly, they are from a horror movie — or
rather, a horror franchise.
These outfits prove that the series will reference
the late '80s horror film Hellraiser in at
least one upcoming episode.
The whole universe in which Rick and Beth
wear these costumes appears to be a parody
of the Hellraiser world, and the get-ups look
like mildly toned-down versions of what the
film's extra-dimensional Cenobite beings wear.
The darts in Beth's face feel like a clever
twist on the iron nails that the film's main
antagonist, Pinhead, has all over his face.
Additionally, in the background of one scene
from the trailer are two creatures who appear
to be riffs on Hellraiser's creepier Cenobites.
In particular, the one with no eyes and who
bears all of its teeth looks exactly like
Chatterer, Hellraiser's right-hand man.
The one between Rick and Beth, with half of
its face splayed open, could be a very subtle
reference to Angelique from Hellraiser: Bloodline,
though it's more likely that this one is a
Rick and Morty original.
The thought of his longtime crush Jessica
being a significant part of his life is enough
to make Morty scream until he passes out.
That thought will apparently become a reality
in Rick and Morty season 5, as the trailer
shows two separate instances in which Jessica
appears as part of Smith-Sanchez family adventures.
Though she has been seen in missions with
the crew before, some were non-canonical and
these season 5 moments hold much more weight.
Early in the trailer, there's a scene involving
giant, Transformers-esque robots.
Upon first glance, it looks like Rick, Morty,
and Summer are in the battle arena, but it's
actually Rick, Morty, and Jessica.
Why would Jessica be involved in such a strange
quest?
The answer lies in the first-look clip from
season 5, the same one that revealed Mr. Nimbus.
In that clip, Morty calls Jessica and confesses
his affection for her.
Much to Morty's surprise, Jessica admits she
has feelings for Morty too, and invites him
to watch a movie with her that night.
Though it's not explained in the new trailer,
that moment should happen in season 5 and
mark the beginning of a relationship between
Jessica and Morty.
Of course, the most important detail in the
whole trailer comes right at the end: New
episodes of Rick and Morty will be portaling
into this universe on Adult Swim on Sunday,
June 20 at 11 PM ET.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.